la ville de longueuil a annoncé à la fin
novembre que des dizaines de cerfs de
virginie qui avait élu domicile dans un
parc allait être euthanasié à la semaine
verte nous avions abordé au printemps
dernier l'enjeu de la surabondance
dessert
les routes du québec traverse b souvent
village zones agricoles forêts
et ne sont pas toujours sûr surtout en
début de soirée où les rencontres sont
parfois imprévisibles
[Musique]
ce genre d'accident impliquant un cerf
de virginie a doublé depuis huit ans au
québec passant d'environ 4000 en 2012 à
plus de 8000 en 2020
c'est un pacte avec des cervidés font
près de 400 blessés chaque année
[Musique]
plusieurs de ces collisions surviennent
dans les régions du sud du québec où les
serres abonde un peu partout
beaucoup
ici on les surprend sur une terre
agricole
là bas on les retrouve dans les cours
arrière de résidence durant l'hiver où
il se régale dans les haies de cèdres
le cerf de virginie un cervidé de la
famille des chevreuils a une durée de
vie d'environ une dizaine d'années
la plupart des animaux qu'on a
domestiqué dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ce sont des ongulés donc c'est des
animaux qui en général sont tolérants la
présence humaine donc les moutons les
chèvres
les vaches on est toutes la même famille
des ongulés des ruminants comme un cerf
de virginie le ministère de la faune
évalue aujourd'hui cette population à
250 mille têtes au québec près de 325 me
dit si on inclut ceux de l'île
d'anticosti c'est le double de
l'inventaire réalisé il ya 30 ans
même si leur nombre varie beaucoup selon
les secteurs plus de la moitié des
populations de cerfs sont concentrées
dans le sud du québec
quand on est davantage dans des régions
sans du québec estrie montérégie
on est vraiment dans des populations à
bordeaux
à certains endroits on peut compter
jusqu'à 35 au kilomètre carré alors
qu'une densité viable pour l'habitat est
estimé à environ 3,5 serre ou kilomètres
carrés
quand qu'on arrive au delà du saint
sacrement corée où est-ce qu'on peut
même arriver dans ces régions-là plus de
dix ans que le mètre carré là on
commence à avoir des dommages au niveau
de l'habitat des problèmes de
cohabitation
donc le oui on peut parler vraiment de
population très abondants
cette vidéo amateur montre une
quarantaine de cerfs de virginie
traversant la route du port à nicolet
un rituel qu'il répète matin et soir
durant l'hiver
[Musique]
la surabondance des serres n'affecte pas
uniquement les zones rurales
un grand nombre d'entre eux se déplacent
vers des secteurs plus urbanisée de la
montérégie
grâce à des corridors naturels comme des
colts des boisés ou des terres agricoles
les serres peuvent avoir accès au parc
de longueuil et de saint-bruno puis à
ceux des îles de boucherville et l'est
de montréal
lorsque les ressources sont abondantes
les jeunes femmes elle a un ennemi vont
vont se reproduire et très rapidement
deux ennemis ou endroits des jumeaux et
triplés
c'est ce qui se passe à longueuil dans
le parc michel chartrand où on observe
un surpeuplement des cerfs de virginie
[Musique]
la population de cervidés est passé
d'environ soixante dix au printemps
dernier à près d'une centaine
aujourd'hui c'est 5 fois la capacité que
peut recevoir le parc
plusieurs dizaines d'appels par année
pour des accidents de voiture mais aussi
toutes sortes de cas qu'on voit donc les
sacs et reste coincé sur une clôture
citoyenne parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez
de nourriture d'un papillon qui sortent
du parc et la marque finalement dans des
souffrances atroces
aujourd'hui c'est l'équilibré écologique
du parc qui est rompu son reboisement ne
peut se faire tant et aussi longtemps
que les serres surexploite le milieu
le cerf cache la forêt le cerf est une
espèce magnifique charismatique on aime
tous il le dommages à la forêt de r on
vous prive que pour ali très discret
mais il est présent il connaît comme un
fou qui vous le résultat ça fait d'un
thème d'année que ces brutes et de façon
chronique et vient elle aussi les
espèces envahissantes qui en profite
plus on attend plus problème est
important plus les effets sont
dévastateurs sur le parquet plus il va
devoir y avoir un nombre important
d'animaux dans l'opération maintenant on
est au pied du mur on n'a pas le choix
d'intervenir les options sont variés
mais controversé sur le plan éthique par
exemple plusieurs citoyens se demandent
pourquoi la ville ne procède pas une
relocalisation des serres dire l'argent
nature ailleurs c'est une fausse
solution saas et fire a été mesuré une
grande proportion des animaux morts dans
l'année qui suit donc les tic masse est
questionnable
pourquoi ne pas les stériliser
s'interroge ceux qui souhaitent
conserver les serres dans leur parc la
difficulté c'est que on n'est pas encore
tout à fait au point que les
contraceptifs ou quand même probablement
les captures et l'injecté donc sa
demande l'immobilisation chimique des
animaux donc ça impose un stress puis
cette méthode ne l ai pas permanente
nécessairement
en raison de la proximité des
habitations
la chasse contrôlée est impossible dans
le pack michel chartrand la seule
solution retenue par la ville la capture
et l'euthanasie
d'ici le printemps prochain soit juste
avant la période de mise bas entre 50 et
80 cervidés sont abattus des
scientifiques sont sur place pour
encadrer les opérations
ça va être simplement des cages tout
impressionné lessard on rentre à
l'intérieur des décalages pour se
nourrir et ils seront un canadien par
des vétérinaires compétent sur place une
dizaine de cervidés seulement pourraient
être épargnés durant l'opération est
peut-être moins
mais oui l'objectif est d'abaisser la
capacité était capable de soutenir le
parc on parle de dictature et même
encore loin d'avoir avoir des expertises
scientifiques là dessus parce que ce
qu'on comprend c'est qu'il de certains
ce serait dans un parc en santé ce qui
est loin d'être le code parc michel
chartrand
les experts craignent que la place
laissée vacante par l'abattage entraîne
une nouvelle introduction de cervidés
provenant cette fois ci des autres parcs
urbains de la région
[Musique]
la ville de longueuil espère ainsi
devenir un modèle d'intervention auprès
des autres municipalités aux prises
elles aussi avec une surpopulation de
cerfs de virginie maintenant mais je
pense que les autres événements aussi
pouvoir s'inspirer de ce qui s'est fait
chez nous longueuil va pouvoir jouer un
rôle de leadership heures à cet égard
l'est pour voir comment est ce qu'on est
capable de prendre des mesures pour
s'assurer une et l'équilibré écologique
de nos espaces naturels de nos
écosystèmes haussmann
[Musique]